hoy se cumple en 40 días desde el
fallecimiento de matsaminis esa joven
curda de 22 años que estaba de visitante
eran y que murió después de haber sido
capturada por la policía de la moral y
según la costumbre la tradición iraní es
una fecha especial es el día en que la
familia vuelve a reunirse a recordar la
memoria del fallecido y también lo hace
con la comunidad Así que esta mañana se
reunieron cientos de personas en el
cementerio de la ciudad de sagués en el
kurdistán iraní de donde era originaria
maxa pero lo hicieron con dificultades
porque desde anoche hubo un gran
despliegue de seguridad evitando que hoy
se celebrara o que se reuniera la
comunidad para recordar a esta joven Así
que muchas personas llegaron caminando
llegaron a través del río y lograron
reunirse donde cantaron eslóganes como
que el kurdistán es la tumba de los de
los fascismos o también gritaban muerte
al dictador y esto sucede en un día en
que la mayoría de colegios y
universidades en el tan iraní no están
activos supuestamente les dieron el día
libre por contaminación pero también hay
una gran huelga en los comercios esto se
extiende a muchos lugares de Irán donde
esta tarde a las 5 hora local están
convocadas marchas de protestas sin
embargo desde esta mañana ya hemos visto
movilizaciones en algunos sectores de
Teherán especialmente el comité médico
de el país que se ha mostrado en contra
del dictamen de los forenses de masa a
Mini y también hemos visto también cómo
se reúnen en algunas otras ciudades pero
sin embargo esto sigue estando
concentrado en las universidades donde
se ha recordado la memoria de esta joven